imagine it's a great sense of reluctance
you've announced these these job cuts
today
and well absolutely it is we'd uh hope
to be
uh back up to speed by now as indeed uh
had the old the whole airline industry
but it's not happened and i think the
airline industry like the club industry
is suffering from treme a tremendous
number of
changes of direction as opposed to
keeping it simple
like they've done in sweden with rules
that everyone can
understand hand washing and social
distancing common sense
we jump from pillar to post to circuit
uh breaking to um
mingling to uh now curfews is the latest
thing
and do you think this 10 p.m closing
time is proportionate
it's utterly stupid because what you've
got at the moment
ian is you got 3.2 million hospitality
workers trying their very best to
enforce
social distancing rules which people
will obey if they think they're in
their best interests and
what they're what they're doing is
they're making those people
redundant at 10 p.m or so in the evening
and turning everyone out into the street
so
what are 19 20 21 euros going to do go
home to mum
we've done a good job at social
distancing in parts
so fuller's and so most pubs
and and uh there's hardly any infections
being passed on in pubs
800 of our 861 pubs
have had no infections whatsoever
another 40 have had one infection
if it was desperately infectious in pubs
you wouldn't get pubs with one
case so it's mad nuts
simon let me bring in you've been
nodding vigorously to a lot of what tim
has been saying there um
is the pub sector being unfairly treated
given the way that it's worked closely
with the government on things like track
and trace
well completely you have to bear in mind
that we reopened on the 4th of july
implementing protocols that we had
worked on with government
to make sure that we could operate
safely for our colleagues and our
customers
there is no evidence that the increase
in cases which are around 4
000 a day it is originating from pubs
it's less than
4.8 of cases originating from pubs
and so to see the sector singled out by
the government
overnight as being part of the problem
is completely unjust uh demoralizing for
so many people that are going to lose
their jobs through this pandemic
pubs can actually be part of the
solution they are not part of the
problem it is a heavily regulated
industry
where we have successfully worked with
the government worked across the entire
sector
to put protocols in place to ensure that
everybody is safe in pubs
so the government should actually be
encouraging people to socialize
in pubs not in people's houses and as
tim said
not spilling out into the street going
back to mum and dad and back to other
families to infect
potentially other people pubs are the
home
of responsible socialising and the
government should be actually
encouraging people to socialize in a
regulated environment
not an unregulated environment simon do
you worry that
we could see a return to uh i mean we've
obviously seen opening hours liberalised
over the last couple of decades or so i
mean in the old days you used to have
this sort of half hour closing time
swill where everyone would knock back
three or four pints
ahead of closing time do you think you
could see behavior like that re-emerging
i i don't know ian we're really
digesting what's happening and trying to
absorb
um the consequences for not only fillers
but for the whole sector
i think what people have seen in the
northeast uh over the last four days
is that that loss of one hour really
impacts consumer confidence
so sales in the northeast i believe have
been down something like
50 for an industry that was already
dealing with the
potential end of the furlough period
that will be absolutely crippling and
the effect it will have
on consumer confidence uh will be
enormous
it brings me back to really what the
prime minister did on the 16th of march
where he uh kept the sector open
but put words out to discourage anybody
from going to pubs
he should be doing the opposite he
should be encouraging people to
socialize
in pubs not at home or in the street
tim i guess uh one of the particularly
contradictory uh signals
being sent out here is the fact that
this comes so soon after the success of
eat out to help out
well the whole thing is uh is is nuts
and we're going from pillar to post
i'm fairly certain the government hasn't
got a clue what it's doing
the most important thing in our
democracy is for
parliament now to take control of this
matter
because there's a very large body of
opinion from professors
gupta um hennigan
michael levitt in america and many many
others who say
that social distancing and hygiene are
the only
scientific methods and what's happening
is a bunch of colleagues many of whom
haven't been elected
are imposing rule by decree as
uh as graham davey has said uh
graham brady has said is a conservative
mp parliament should now take a week to
debate this and the question for
parliament is
do lockdowns work and if they
go into that in detail and forget about
political loyalty
and try and get the heart of the problem
they're intelligent people that's why
they've been elected
they'll say lockdowns don't work there's
a lot of other things that do
but they don't simon is it possible to
put a number on how much this is going
to cost you in terms of lost sales
i'm not even really interested in lost
sales at the moment i'm more concerned
with
lost jobs lost livelihood the morale and
the mental health of my team
and these are all things that are far
more important to me than lost sales
i think this will be devastating for the
industry but it will be devastating for
so many
people they're going to be cut adrift
predominantly people who are
under 30 they're going to lose their
jobs as a result of
i i'll repeat what tim said some
completely incoherent and
inconsistent government strategies to
deal with this virus
do you have any faith in the government
to be able to mitigate uh potential job
losses in the sector simon
well there are things that if the
governments are going to persist with
this
this approach there are things the
government can still do you know we have
a furlough
scheme that um is due to end at the end
of end of october
we still as a sector have just over 900
000 people on furlough the government
must extend the furlough period if
they're going to implement
this curfew they simply must extend it
for the hospitality sector
they're going to need to give further
vat support to the sector to keep it
afloat
we want to minimize and i'm sure tim's
in the same boat as me
we want to minimize the number of jobs
that are lost and the only way that we
can minimize a number of jobs that lost
is the government extends the support
that they've given so far
and does not impose draconian actions on
the industry
tim you go along with that does a
furlough scheme need to be extended for
hospitality
well you can do that it's a and probably
you have to it's a sticking plaster
thing the problem is
you've got people running the country
now who buy their actions
have no knowledge of money whether spoon
alone
just weatherspoon never mind uh you know
it's only a small part of the overall
industry pays 1
000 its customers staff and
the company pays one pound in every
thousand of uk
taxes you shut us down and
uh you're already in financial problems
so there is no magic money tree from
much more furlough
the problem is these jokers are ruining
the country
do you think tim that uh boris johnson's
been got up by the likes of chris whitty
and sir patrick valancin
i don't know but at the moment he's
definitely not
up to the job the job of someone running
a business
like simon does or i do is to
listen to what experts have to say
decide what should happen
and steer a sensible path making sure
you're listening
at all times what boris is doing i
suspect
he's got some opinion polls that say if
you close down pubs which a lot of
people believe
then you will reduce the level of effect
infections
the fact is it's not true and boris has
to explain
that to people which he's not doing as
does
michael gove and others so we need
leadership
and common sense and good economics
those only with those things together
that everyone can have the things that
they expect and want
from a country like britain the economy
is being ruined
fast we're spending more money than we
spend in wars
and we haven't had a war simon you've
yet to reopen some of your city center
pubs including a couple of my favorites
here in the square mile
is is there a danger that these sites
are never going to reopen
we we were slightly we were planning to
build momentum during september
and open the remainder of our estate and
she said in in particular in central
london
this um plan to impose a curfew and also
let me remind you uh tell people to
carry on working from home
shut the front door work from home don't
socialize for six months
is going to massively impact central
london and city centers
um we will have to now revisit our plan
to reopen our pubs
we wanted to reopen our pub so that we
could save the jobs
um that plan will have to be revisited
it's it's heartbreaking for everybody
and as tim said the logic behind this is
non-existent the evidence that pubs
are part of the problem is non-existent